The answer is the third choice, and it's really only necessary to provide the nonce,
but it's helpful to provide the k value as well.
What B needs to check--once this nonce is provided
B can check that the incription using A's public key of the output, which is the y2 value,
with the nonce added--that was the part that Alice removed.
What Bob needs to do is check that that output is equal to x of k.
And that value was provided directly to B, because all of the inputs from two links ago,
went into this mix as well as the outputs from A.
This proves to B that for that particular output that B asked for,
that that corresponds to one of the inputs to A.
We can do the same thing all the way down the chain.
That means that A will provide its outputs both to B and C.
C will be able to verify that B did the mix correctly by picking some random ones,
and having B prove that they're correct.
And at the final stage, B will provide its outputs to C as well as some validator
who can validate that C did the correct thing.